a scary moment for Queen Elizabeth after
another major break-in at Buckingham
Palace here are the scary details it was
2 a.m. Wednesday morning the 93 year old
Queen
asleep in her royal chamber when a 22
year old man scaled the fence at the
palace for what's really terrifying
the intruder reportedly roamed around
Buckingham for a few minutes before
being arrested he had no weapon and
please don't think the scary incident
was terrorist-related the palace had no
comment but was this a copycat break-in
in July of 1982 this man Michael Fagan
also climbed the gates and actually got
inside the Queen's bedroom with her in
it
props to Her Majesty who calmly spoke to
Fagin for about 10 minutes before help
finally arrived between her family are
prepared for intruders and possible
attacks they get survival training from
the British military one of the most
difficult things to sort of plan against
is you know people with mental health
problems that's probably the biggest
single threat to any member of the royal
family and another royal story making
headlines Duchess Megan as being mom
shamed because something she didn't have
a firm grip on baby Archie at
yesterday's polo match Twitter trolls
have posted quote she's going to drop
that baby and the way little Archie is
being held scary
Megan is also being called out for
Artie's hatless head and no socks but
Rory all insiders tell us actually Megan
is a good mom I think she has been
incredibly confident as a first-time
mother I was told that she's taken to it
like a duck to water
[Music]